which is a classic pattern breaking
through in the center it is shuffled his
Rook over to G3 he gave up the pawn on
C5 and sacrifices on H7 there's that
double X Clan move driving the king out
into the open involving the queen with
check Queen H6 might actually be the
move that Vladimir ivich missed although
94 was also strong this forces the
decisive weakening of the dark squares
and now Simon we're so used to the move
Rook to H3 in this type of position that
is the pattern that we're all familiar
with this is what ivich was relying on
he's controlling that square but the
Rook goes to the other side Rook to F3
and Knight F6 is completely Unstoppable
Exquisite attacking prowess by the 14
year olds who uh counts with a
impressive rating of 2500 on the nose
that rating is about to go up quite a
bit and that title
that will be a g pretty shortly I think
Simon I think the cup date gorrell
Eddies the Turkish Vietnam has in fact
secured uh victory over velamir ivich
that is the first decisive game
but very far from the last evich will
have to win with the white pieces
tomorrow on demand in order to force the
playoffs
um on the third day